[Musique]
8h30 samedi matin sur le parvis de
l'église dans le quartier saint-roch à
québec on installe les kiosques du
marché public croccel rock un marché
solidaire c'est un marché solidaire mais
j'aime aussi penser que c'est un marché
populaire
c'est sûr que on parle vraiment l'équipe
tête du vénérable message est populaire
parce que ça parle aussi à tout le monde
la sécurité alimentaire est un enjeu
pris un ton quartier avait de nombreux
défis pour bien s'alimenter dans le
quartier roc dont le manque d'argent
pour combler les besoins de passe et
l'accessibilité à des aliments frais et
sains
le jour avant le marché xavier le
coordonnateur du projet fait sa tournée
après le marché de sainte foy ils
rencontrent les producteurs au grand
marché de québec pommes de terre
poireaux choux navets tabago l'au delà
si vous avez besoin
il récupère l'abondance des récoltes
d'automne de différents maraîchers
pendant ce temps à quelques pas de là
marie-andrée termine la récolte des
légumes et complète la commande de
xavier on it au jardin du bassin louise
c'est une ferme urbaine à vocation
sociale et pédagogique
donc on fait pousser le plus de légumes
possible pour vendre à très très très
beaux prix à des organismes sécurité
alimentaire et on aspire vraiment à
faire pousser ce que veulent
cherchez
les boeufs carottes temps ne trahissent
pas ce que bénévole qui se fait pas
dicter treize à la douzaine comme le
maïs pour certains que le brocoli soit 6
dollars ça devient un enjeu messier
vendu à une et 50 v ça devient réaliste
donc nous on le fait cette association
avec eux c'est une façon de faire un
lien y parle locale tous ensemble ils
développent un système alimentaire
accessible durable mais aussi local les
aliments pousse dans des fermes situées
à moins de 40 km
c'est pas mal complet là ouais je ramène
ce à l'église une photo de préparer le
marché pour demain
un peu plus loin louez michel monte sur
le toit vert de l'édifice frédéric back
dans ce jardin collectif eux ou s'ils
récoltent aujourd'hui
ces surplus de récolte des amis de la
terre sont donnés chaque semaine ou
marché solidaire ont cherché à éviter le
gaspillage de partager des bonbons à ce
que le mandat d'arrêt c'est à vélo que
michel se rend au marché va porter tous
les dons on parle souvent des déserts
alimentaires on a parfois pour les
consciences que si on n'a pas de voiture
on it à mobilité réduite comment ça peut
être difficile à s'approvisionner en
fruits et légumes donc nous revient peut
pas dire à cette flotte feu les souris
ont fait des portions pour une somme
entre gan solidaire bataille de naboo
ok
dès l'ouverture du marché les gens
abonde on achète à petit prix souvent
aussi à l'unité on peut payer plus et
faire une contribution solidaire ou
encore prendre des aliments gratuitement
sous le saccharose
[Musique]
on peut vraiment acheter à l'unité donc
un kabyle se piquer pas énormément
dessous peut très bien se faire son
panier avec son budget de 3 4 ou 5
dollars moi j'y vis dans le quartier j'y
travaille dans le quartier c'est
collectif c'est une cause derrière soupe
c'est seul gène il redonne aux gens
démunis et en a beaucoup dans le coin
c'est un donc on peut faire toutes les
semaines dans tout ça nourrit nos mâles
avec des légumes frais
[Musique]
historiquement le parvis de l'église
c'est autant un lieu des changes si
c'est un peu l'idée aussi à la base
c'est d'avoir une belle mixité de tous
les citoyens qui cohabitent dans le
quartier
plaisir six soldats pour le maraîcher
aussi une certaine valeur de leur
travail donc on va chez plon en
abondance
un ensemble d'organismes et de bénévoles
sont impliqués dans le succès du projet
lorsque j'ai pris ma retraite j'ai
commencé à découvrir le quartier saint
sauveur saint roch et à m'impliquer dans
les organismes communautaires ce que je
trouve intéressant du marché c'est le
contact avec les gens
chacun
met la sécurité alimentaire est une
réalité tout au long de l'année le
marché continuera cet hiver à
l'intérieur on veut que tout le monde
puisse manger à sa faim à son goût dans
l'intimité puis en plus on aimerait ça
que ce soit plus le cas justement
rappelé
aussi qu'il sortait du marché j'espère
que ça va passer du temps dans un
quartier qui sont avec
[Musique]